[Music]
hi everyone I'm Jessica cousins and I am
an AI policy specialist with the future
of life Institute as well as a research
fellow with the UC Berkeley Center for
long-term cyber security so you've
already heard really fantastic talks
from both Allen and Brian landscaping
the issues and the actors related to the
strategy and coordination and governance
of AI and AGI development so I won't
talk more about that range of issues
here just flag really quickly that the
future of life Institute does have a
resource page on AI policy which is
future of life org slash AI policy and
there's also going to be a breakout
session tomorrow I believe at 1:00 p.m.
talking about global governance of AGI
if that interests you further so what
I'm going to share now is a more brief
summary of the strategy discussion that
has taken place over the last couple
days here at the workshop the goal of
this is just transparency and help make
sure that everyone's on the same page
for the continuing discussions we'll
have over the next three days of the
beneficial AGI conference so this
morning you heard about some of the
speculative future destinations that
have gained traction from participants
here and these provide useful
inspiration to the work that we're
engaged with but given the complexity
and the diversity of what is at stake
even more important than defining the
contours of a space where we want to be
is to identify those shared goals and
commonalities among a range of diverse
actors so you've heard your you've heard
some of those commonalities across the
destinations already features such as
humility robustness flexibility autonomy
peacefulness and the reduction of
suffering and these desired features can
really help guide us towards the AGI
futures that we want and our strategy is
to get there so to make it through this
period safely and into a post AGI world
we need to keep these features in mind
but we also need to chart paths required
to help us get to futures we all enjoy
so yesterday morning we worked through a
of scenarios to help us imagine the
possibility space for example we were
asked to imagine the character of Bob
and this was from Joe Harrah's great
talks to please find him to give him the
credit he deserves for this so bob is a
leader at a major company seeking to
develop AGI he goes to meetings like
this one he knows there are strategic
challenges associated with AGI and he's
seeking advice what do you tell him
maybe the current narratives of tech
utopia on one hand and existential
threats on the other are not the most
compelling narratives so what do we have
at our disposal it was suggested that we
can look at three interconnected
elements development deployment and
landscape when it comes to development
of AGI what are the levers that matter
most for starters data so we need
responsible data use policies what kind
of information will Bob have access to
what will he share he will also need
sufficiently secure and efficient
hardware other factors that influence
development include questions related to
control incentives and openness maybe
Bob needs a charter to indicate his
willingness to be transparent about the
status of his company's technology maybe
he needs to know how to design safety
reliability and accountability into his
processes from the outset and how will
he measure resiliency across all of
these fronts
how will he protect his networks from
cyber attacks when it comes time for
deployment
Bob's concerns will only grow not only
does he need to think about all of the
issues already mentioned but he has to
assess the general generality and
capability of the systems and the
domains of their application what uses
are illegal what uses are dangerous what
uses could be co-opted or results in a
public backlash against his company as
for the landscape Bob probably needs to
accept that his company does not exist
in a vacuum but that he has to assess
his position along
a complex landscape of actors social
cultural and environmental realities
economic constraints and security
considerations
does he have partnerships with Amazon or
Google is his work supported by his
national government might people see his
tool as a symbol of change they don't
want leading to the equivalent of
throwing rocks at the Google buses what
if he ends up automating people's jobs
will foreign governments see his
development as a threat obviously bob
has a lot to think about
but really as Bob's advisors we have a
lot to think about how can we boil down
our recommendations and improve our
messaging so that he quickly understands
the difficulties and steps he can take
to help create more beneficial AGI in
the workshop we focused on scenario
roleplay as a mechanism through which to
explore the motivations of different
actors and the kinds of developments
that increase the chances of global
coordination as was pointed out being
Bob for an hour can make you a better
Bob advisor so we split into many
different groups and played out numerous
scenarios intended to depict a variety
of possible probable and surprising
futures in which each person took on the
role of different actors influencing the
scenario the insights from these
breakouts are really interesting people
found that the fall to negative outcomes
happens quickly and could be the
decision of just one prominent actor
they also had frustrations that they
didn't have more tools to leverage even
if they held a position of seemingly
great power people struggle to find ways
to credibly commit to global or
bilateral coordination with existing
paradigms and in some scenarios the
gradual and subtle use of AGI prevented
other actors from knowing of its
existence and being able to make
proactive decisions about how to respond
in scenarios where one country's
industry and government were not working
together efficiently they experienced a
harder time responding to global threats
P
also found that if top AI researchers
could communicate one coherent message
about risks to their government it
worked a lot better than having that
community display on the more positive
side people found that implementing
concrete channels for monitoring and
communication increased overall feelings
of agency moreover having shared
knowledge of mutually harmful effects
contributed to coordination as did the
perception that everyone was relatively
aware of the capabilities of their
adversaries one group found that the
desire to build technology faster
actually led to greater global
coordination because researchers needed
to share and discuss their findings they
instituted an AI Olympics to further
propel innovation overall many groups
found the majority of global players
were incentivized to cooperate in order
to realize the benefits of the
technologies and prevent an increasing
number of catastrophes so stepping back
into reality there was also a really
great panel yesterday that elucidated
key issues to be aware of in the
strategy space participants highlighted
the need to think about who the relevant
actors are and how stable that
configuration is into the future to
question the institutions and the
processes determining the rules and
whether it's actually working well for
people and how to determine how broadly
to share results in sensitive research
participants also talked about how to
facilitate global coordination and
suggested that current institutions are
not sufficient and many people feel
disconnected and even alienated from
their political systems it was also
pointed out that emerging laws for AI
like the bot disclosure act in
California for example might be
important practice for the community -
in supporting the application of rules
to ml systems so participants of the
workshop have proposed a variety of
action items and these should be carried
into the conference for consideration as
we all continue to identify further
action items over the next three days so
there have been tons of really great
ideas proposed and I'm not gonna go into
all of them now just give just share a
few ideas that have come out
that were mentioned fairly consistently
or that got some positive feedback so
one participant emphasized the
importance of targeted conferences so
you can all feel good about being here
and other ideas have included blockchain
coordination tools anonymous markets for
whistleblowing establishing new AI
narratives in the media credibly
signaling trust from AI organizations
establishing a unified framework of AI
social responsibility that is trackable
facilitating the use of ml and Social
Sciences and civic tech instituting a
new governance regime that implements
private regulators who are designated by
the government identifying the early
wins in AI policy that translate to more
advanced systems for example by
implementing standards for transparency
and accountability improving
documentation of impact and performance
evaluation of AML models leveraging the
many areas of commonality across AI
policy around the world to support
international cooperation and we've
heard some great areas of commonality
between the US and China and Brian's
talk establishing rules for the use of
AI and militaries and critical
decision-making and enabling commitments
for coordination and resource sharing
prior to the emergence of AGI and the
windfall Clause that Ellen mentioned is
another great example of that so if any
of these ideas spark interest for you
feel free to find me I can connect you
to the right person and then enter your
own ideas on the Google spreadsheet so
across all of the ideas that people have
proposed so far for strategically
reaching our goals a number of themes
have already emerged the first one is
that there are actions to be taken by a
broad diversity of actors there have
been actions identified for people in AI
research and development in operations
and communications in academia and civil
society and in the government so
hopefully that fact encourages you that
whatever brought you here however you
got here there are paths being
highlighted that can help you identify
ways to support safe and beneficial AGI
a second theme that emerged was to
identify the comparative advantage that
you may have and target your actions
toward those with significant impact our
opportunity and a final theme of the
actions proposed is that many of them
require at least some degree of
institutional change whether to
establish greater accountability within
organizations or even to rethink the way
that we govern technology altogether so
I think that points to the difficulty of
the task ahead of us but I'd guess that
this group might be up to the challenge
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]